vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir les résultats
législatives sénégalaises ont été
publiés et c'est historique la coalition
présidentielle a perdu la majorité
absolue fixée à 83 sièges à l'assemblée
nationale mais avec 80 sièges
l'opposition n'est pas non plus en
position de gouverner seul il va falloir
à présent négocier trois petits partis
de vienne faisant deux rois pour ces
élections une situation inédite au
sénégal nous consacrons une large partie
de ce journal à ces résultats
la tension monte au kenya cinq jours des
élections générales le candidat williams
routot dénoncent une campagne de
désinformation contre lui fait pour
entraîner des violences et lui faire
perdre l'élection
l'onu dit avoir des preuves solides de
la présence des troupes rwandaises aux
côtés des rebelles du m23 nous serons en
ligne avec le chercheur et ghanmi berry
puisse lui ces élections pour l'institut
congolais de recherche sur la politique
on ouvre ce journal par les résultats
législatives sénégalaise pour la
première fois de son histoire le parti
au pouvoir perd la majorité absolue
fixée à 83 sièges avec 80 de benno
bocchia car n'est pas en mesure de
gouverner seul mais la grande coalition
de l'opposition et us can oui non plus
avec ses 80 députés les petits candidats
deviennent naturellement des nouveaux
faiseurs de roi on part tout de suite à
dakar ont trouvé notre correspondant
elimane dao elimane ça y est les
résultats des élections après plusieurs
jours d'attenté ont été publiés et la
coalition présidentielle perd la
majorité arsenault
écoutez fatmata oui on peut l'affirmer
la coalition présidentielle bonhomme au
qatar a perdu la majorité absolue a au
terme de ces législatives les résultats
ont été redressés tout à l'heure à la
cour d'appel de dakar avec 82 députés
dans le propriétaire n'a plus la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
lnr pollution d'opposition a composé de
houaïlou un sénégalais y est calme et se
retrouvent ensemble cumuler avec à 80
députés une situation
inédite dans l'histoire politique
sénégalaise jamais on avait au terme
d'élections législatives à une situation
pareille où le pouvoir va devoir
désormais négocier pour garder la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez parlé de l'opposition qui a
déclaré vouloir contester avant même la
publication officielle de ses résultats
qu'en est-il elimane
écouter oui l'opposition à ce matin au
palais de justice de dakar représentée
notamment par son mandataire bt fall a
dénoncé des irrégularités constatées
dans le processus de comptage du vote et
dcti fall qui est le mandataire de la
coalition d'opposition us can rip et
voit le sénégal avait demandé aux juges
de pouvoir accéder à certains résultats
notamment au nord est du pays une
demande qui lui a été refusé et devant
la presse n'était pas là estimé que les
résultats qui seront déclarées par la
coalition rapala par la cour d'appel
n'engagerait pas à l'opposition je les
écoutais derrière moi avant cette
retransmission en direct il se satisfait
tout de même de la percée de l'eau de
l'opposition dans ces élections
législatives et alors que savons-nous de
finalement ce que vont faire ces petits
candidats entre guillemets avec trois
sièges ils deviennent naturellement les
faiseurs de rois de cette élection
assurément ils sont les faiseurs de roi
à l'issue de ces élections il s'agit
entre autres de papa début il file de la
coalition les serviteurs on va dire
arrivé quatrième as dans ces élections
législatives abdoulaye fall un
journaliste qui s'est lancé en politique
il ya trois mois et karl marx en salle
ancien ministre du président macky sall
devenu son farouche opposant et pape
diouf ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale du sénégal ancien maire de
dakar sous le régime du président
abdoulaye wade si l'un des trois on va
dire rejoint la coalition au pouvoir
gbagbo fait hacker à la coalition
présidentielle aura la majorité et si
les trois rejoint d'opposition
l'opposition aura la majorité ils sont à
ce jour les faiseurs de roi a les
individualités qui sont capables de
faire pencher la balance d'un côté ou de
l'autre merci beaucoup et imane daho en
direct de dakar et nous restons
justement sur ce sujet pour analyser ces
résultats on retrouve en direct de dakar
babacar gaye analystes politiques
directeur de publication chez what i un
think tank panafricain basé à dakar
babacar n'diaye vous avez suivi ces
élections pour votre think tank c'est la
première fois que le pouvoir tout
simplement qui est en place perd la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
un scénario inédit pour le sénégal
comment réagissez vous à ces résultats
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment une
situation qui est inédite et tout à
l'heure la commission nationale de
recensement des votes emploi à proclamer
les résultats provisoires
et je dois dire que ce que nous pensions
ce que nous voyons comme scénario s'est
présenté à nous et donc finalement
personne n'a la majorité absolue comme
vous l'avez dit et donc il va falloir au
sein de l'hémicycle au sein de
l'assemblée nationale va falloir nouer
des alliances est donc rappelé jusque là
qu elle son pouvoir aura besoin d'un
député justement pour avoir la majorité
absolue on peut l'appeler les partis
d'opposition dont la coiffure
d'opposition que ce soit lié à ce qu'à
lui et wall ou au besoin donc de trois
députés et finalement finalement fait
inédite ce sont ces trois députés
issus des autres coalitions qui vont
devoir peut-être les terminèrent un peu
de quel côté va penser à la balance pour
cette majorité absolue donc c'est
vraiment une station 13 les détours au
sénégal que le vivons actuellement et
vous avez utilisé le terme historique
c'est bien le cas et alors justement
vous avez parlé avant de parler des
négociations peut être revenir sur les
raisons de cet échec du gouvernement
mais aussi de la très belle performance
info le dire de l'opposition et de cette
inter coalition entre wall ou ayez oui
askan wi comment vous expliquez vous
oui je pense que si nous regardons un
peu la dynamique au sein de l'opposition
sénégalaise avec sur la paix au sénégal
alter coalition entre les basques à
l'étoile où nous avions déjà vu des
signes des résultats aux dernières
locales qui monte qui montraient une
certaine manière que l'opposition était
en train de gagner du terrain et donc
cette élection ils ont mis en place des
stratégies
il ya eu des alliances notamment sur des
localités des zones où une coalition a
accepté de leur coalition s'inquiéter en
ce qu'ils étaient en mesure justement de
gagner sa localité là et donc voilà
depuis quelques mois ils ont défini
ensemble une stratégie est plus qu on
regarde de plus près ce qui se passe sur
le terrain finalement cette stratégie-là
a été payant pour la coalition il ya ce
cas nuit et wallons mais alors pour vous
bakanja et c'est la défaite de la
coalition au pouvoir ou est ce que c'est
une percée historique fable et 2 vous
pouvez me dire pour l'opposition
non je pense que c'est un peu des deux
parce que effectivement l'opposition a
mis en place une stratégie les murs
organiser notre côté aussi il faut dire
que nous sommes dans une phase de fin de
mandat pour le présent macky sall et
donc il ya eu des choix aussi qui ont
été faits sur des personnes durant ces
élections législatives il ya aussi eu
malheureusement pas vraiment de débat
programmatique j'allais dire et donc
d'autres faits aussi sont ajoutés à ces
élections législatives est donc
finalement aussi lorsqu'on le met dans
la contexte a quand même qui est assez
difficile pour les sénégalais je veux
dire avec flambée des prix une inflation
aussi qui est du but d'être atteint de
manière à ce qu'il se passe en ukraine
et en russie finalement il ya un
contexte et qui a peut-être permis aussi
que l'opposition fasse une percée qui
est encore plus important qu'au local
est finalement aussi que la majorité au
pouvoir perd 2 finalement du terrain
parce qu'il faut se rappeler qu'en 2007
la coalition au pouvoir avec 125 députés
sur 165 et là d'une élection à l'autre
on passe de ces chiffres là un chiffre
de 82 députés donc ça veut dire que
vraiment il ya eu dynamique assez
importante au sein de l'opposition
sénégalaise et qui explique aujourd'hui
ses résultats que nous avons et alors
babacar niasse dit nous vous avez
mentionné macky sall ce scrutin test
c'est le dernier avant la future
présidentielle de février 2000 24 quelle
quelle leçon le président sénégalais
devrait-il en tirer finalement de ses
résultats
je pense que il faut toujours tirer des
leçons d'une élection etc ect ect
créatif justement le monde qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à analyser leur
première séquence qui va vite arriver
juste après cette élection législative
ça va être la nomination d'un premier
ministre justement qui revient dans
l'after architecture fonctionnelle et
donc le présent maquisards va devoir
nommer un ministre et en nouveau
gouvernement donc on va se mettre en
place il s'agira de voir un peu quelles
sont les personnes qui seront choisis
dans ce nouveau gouvernement est ce que
finalement une lecture plus global de
l'élection des élections législatives va
lui permettre d'apporter un nouveau
regard sur la situation sachant qu on
est à un an et demi des êtres de
l'élection présidentielle qui aura lieu
en janvier 2004 donc vraiment une
situation qui est inédite à tout point
de vue absolument au sénégal et donc il
faudra aussi tirer toutes les leçons et
sa configuration nouvelle aussi va
permettre au sénégal
les bonnes questions à mon avis merci
beaucoup bacar dia et nous suivrons
évidemment les suites de ces élections
législatives au sénégal et vous l'avez
dit justement sur les décisions que
pourront prendre le président en place
et la coalition évidemment de
l'opposition merci beaucoup babacar gaye
élections toujours mais au kenya où la
tension monte à mesure que la date du
scrutin approche le 9 août prochain le
candidat
william route au vice-président actuel
se dit victime de menaces une campagne
de désinformation serait à l'oeuvre pour
entraîner des violences et lui faire
perdre l'opposition car chose inédite
bien que vice président le président lui
soutient l'opposition anaérobie bastien
renault
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
vice président kényan annonce qu'il
pourrait y avoir des manipulations du
scrutin il approche de cette élection
mais cette fois ci il a été résolument
alarmiste parlant notamment de fait qui
lui venait de la vallée du rift son
bastion où il y aurait des intimidations
des lecteurs ou ses opposants tiendrais
des discours qui appellent à la violence
qui font peur à ses électeurs et qui
pourrait bien les empêcher de se rendre
aux urnes le jour du scrutin mardi
prochain je vous propose d'écouter le
vice président du kenya william ruto qui
parlait ce jeudi matin dans sa résidence
de nairobi
nous avons été informés de l'existence
de réunions secrètes dans le but de
diviser et créer des conflits tous ok
street 10 tramoni tous ok si tu es
conflict oui nous ne pouvons pas rester
les bras croisés et laisser de telles
choses se reproduire au kenya
durant son discours le vice président a
multiplié ces allégations sont pour
autant apporter de preuve il a demandé à
la commission électorale indépendante
est bien de faire des vérifications il a
dit qu'il allait communiquer une liste
de noms de personnes qui tentent
d'influencer les électeurs de manière
illégale en multipliant les menaces ou
encore les pots-de-vin leur a demandé de
s'assurer que le scrutin serait libre
démocratique et transparent il a aussi
appelé l'autorité des télécommunications
vient à maintenir autant que possible la
qualité d'internet afin que les gens
puissent se renseigner qu'ils ne vivent
pas dans l'ombre à la veille de
l'élection qu'ils puissent être au
courant de ce qui se passe à l' approche
du scrutin mardi prochain
on passe à l'autre actualité du jour qui
concerne la république démocratique du
congo avec cette polémique qui concerne
l'aide de l'armée rwandaise apporté aux
rebelles du m23 un groupe d'experts
mandaté par les nations unies dit avoir
ressembler à rassembler des preuves
solides de la présence des troupes de
kigali aux côtés des rebelles on
retrouve pour en parler reggane mais
viry chercheurs a débouté lee institut
congolais de recherche sur la politique
et la gouvernance de la violence
partenaire de recherche du gel
ccrg groupe d'étude sur le congo merci
monsieur minery d'être avec nous alors
dites-nous l'étau se resserre autour de
kigali après le gouvernement congolais
c'est au tour des nations unies
d'annoncer avoir des preuves solides de
la présence de l'armée congolaise aux
côtés du m23
oui en fait c'est un secret de
polichinelle on a parlé depuis très
longtemps mais enfin au delà des preuves
avérées et du prévenu matériel sait qui
est qui ce qui semble être la nouveauté
dans ce rapport est peut-être une
opportunité pour le gouvernement qui
rechignait encore sur l'implication du
rwanda a peut-être cette fois-ci
l'affirmer ouvertement et peut-être vais
aller vers des sanctions
de la pression sur le gouvernement
rendait le gouvernement rwandais
pourtant continue de nier comment
analysez-vous le positionnement de
kigali sur cette question
voilà
ces départs vaut déjà on sait que même
en 2013 le gouvernement rwandais est
entré d'heuliez et les liens pour un
processus de vérification qui a bien mis
à ce que la communauté internationale
puisse l'affirmer encore mais bon cela
n'a pas
empêché et le mal et les états unis et
d'autres gouvernements étrangers 2d
sanctionnées notamment en suspendant les
l'aide publique au développement à
anvers le gréement rouennais mais alors
que peut faire le gouvernement congolais
on a vu des rendez vous diplomatiques
qui se multiplient entre tshisekedi et
kagame et pourtant cela continue
apparemment sur le terrain que peut
faire le gouvernement congolais
je pense que le gouvernement congolais
[Musique]
conforté dans sa position et ainsi elle
peut cette fois ci demande encore un peu
plus de soutien diplomatique et ses
partenaires
même si aussi ce même rapport il évoque
aussi le fait que certains
l'officier est de l'armée congolaise ont
aussi en fait or auraient
travaillé avec des groupes armés locaux
et étrangers c'est qu'il n'est pas aussi
à quelque chose qui
qui puisse être
défendable du point de vue des nations
unies mais aussi du point de vue de la
communauté internationale
courez ghanmi viry de la situer
bouteille merci beaucoup c'est ainsi que
nous refermons ce journal afrique merci
à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis partout
dans le monde et en particulier à toute
la communauté sénégalaise virtuel très
attentive à notre couverture je vous
remercie et vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur france 24
[Musique]